ja mein thema hat in gewisser weise auch
mit der fdp zu tun mit allen parteien
die in sechs oder auf die nächsten 46
stunden extrem blicken in 46 stunden
nicht mal mehr 46 stunden da schließen
die wahllokale in deutschland die
bundestagswahl ist dann geschichte aber
das ergebnis wird feststehen und
mutmaßlich so viele frustrierte wähler
zurücklassen wie nie zuvor frustrierte
wähler weil wir erstmals mutmaßlich eine
dreier-koalition sehen werden ein
bundeskanzler der gewählt wird von
mindestens zwei weiteren parteien das
bedeutet dass in einer koalition aus
drei parteien die einzelnen parteien
relativ wenig nur durchsetzen können und
dann bleiben natürlich die wähler zurück
frustriert die ohnehin andere parteien
gewählt haben und gar nicht an der
regierung beteiligt sind mit anderen
worten deutschland wird ein frust land
und der nächste kanzler wird die aufgabe
haben aus diesem frust politik lust zu
machen das wird das dringlichste und
wichtigste vorhaben des nächstens
kanzlers erstmal sein
demokratie lieber josef ist die
staatsform des institutionalisierten
misstrauens des bürgers gegenüber der
politik gegenüber den regierenden und
was wir jetzt in deutschland erleben das
finde ich auch interessant wie sie das
wir schildern das ist natürlich eine art
ein misstrauensvotum durch
mögliche stimm abstinenz durch tiefere
zustimmungswerte das heißt die politiker
die sich jetzt zur wahl gestellt haben
sind und zu begeistern für einen
beträchtlichen teil der deutschen
öffentlichkeit und das ist eigentlich
ein ganz normaler politischer prozess
und das wird dann die aufgabe diese
politiker seien quasi wenn sie dann
irgendeiner gewählt ist die leute zu
überzeugen also die können dann
eigentlich nur noch ein upside potenzial
haben heute aber habe ich einen
lichtblick gesehen ich fand die rede von
armin laschet die fand ich brillant und
der rotor den satz des wahlkampfs
gesorgt hat nämlich gesagt die soziale
marktwirtschaft
ist das christliche menschenbild
umgesetzt in praktische politik und da
muss ich sagen das ist ein kluger das
ist ein tiefsinniges satz der mich jetzt
persönlich für vieles entschädigt dort
was ich ihnen noch empfinden kann und
laien und sänger räumung möglicherweise
das ist ja schön armin laschet sagt
diesen satz dann 48 stunden 47 stunden
vor schließung der wahllokale
das mag ein bisschen helfen aber
vielleicht hilft es auch nicht richtig
also die union steht zurzeit mit armin
laschet an der spitze zwischen 22 und 25
prozent in den umfragen auch da würde
man sagen sind keine 45 prozent wie
helmut kohl mal hatte oder sogar 48 die
ja auch mal hatte also da gibt es schon
viele viele wählerinnen und wähler in
deutschland die sagen das was armin
laschet sagt selbst wenn es so ein
kluger satz ist wie sie sagen den wollen
wir eigentlich gar nicht als
bundeskanzler haben vielleicht wird das
und dann gibt es ganz ganz viele
frustrierte die sagen nämlich große es
gibt einfach eine wirklich große
unzufriedenheit sicherlich in der
deutschen bevölkerung die sorgen aus da
läuft im raumschiff berlin das geht an
uns vorbei das spricht mich nicht an und
insofern haben sie natürlich recht ist
das auch etwas ein beunruhigendes
symptom ein indiz für eine abgehobenheit
der politischen klasse in der sich die
menschen nicht mehr wiedererkennen
deshalb die tiefen zustimmungswerte oder
was sagt béla anda der schau ganz
schlauen tiere
[Gelächter]
wirklich sympathie für aber was kommt
jetzt kriegt er aber die bewegungen da
kam die spd mit olaf scholz und 15
prozent wo sie fest gemauert waren jetzt
sind sie in allen umfragen wir sonntag
sehen ob es dabei bleibt bei 25 prozent
zehn prozentpunkte mehr anlass ist die
cdu waren bei 35 prozent
dann kam die flut und jetzt ist er bei
22 bis 25 aber vielleicht ist das ja
auch gar nicht so schlecht ja an binnen
dreier konstellation gibt journalist
erwarten die eigentlich sind seit 2005
da haben viele gesetzt auf eine jamaika
koalition die nicht kam vor vier jahren
in jamaica koalition die von christian
lindner aufgekündigt wurde dann an dem
abend alles korrekt sein sie wurde gar
nicht erst in die beute glaube ich jeder
merkel sie nicht so jacobs sagt
christian lindner weil er gedacht hätte
alexander hier hätte den grünen alles
gegeben und ihm nix also insofern hat er
dann gesagt mit mir nicht und jetzt
vielleicht ist das eine tolle mischung
ökologie ökonomie und irgendwas entweder
mehr richtung bürgersinn
freiheitsgedanken absolute
marktwirtschaft oder
auch ein politiker ein junger politiker
zu gast bekommen sie ja wenn es 10,5
prozent nrw ergebnisses müsst ihr im
bundestag sitzen wie hoch ist denn dein
frustration ins level wie siehst du wenn
also der wahlkampf hat schon ein
bisschen frustriert also ich hab mir die
trainer auch angeguckt und es war
irgendwie jetzt nicht wo sie jetzt auch
gesagt haben oder kanzler hat die
aufgabe wieder lust am politik zu machen
und wo das fantasie peters hat jetzt
keiner keiner irgendwie gemacht bei den
trial aber ja ich finde noch etwas
anderes was sehr interessant sein wird
nämlich in der konstellation der dreier
konstellation wird es nicht mehr diesen
einen die eine kanzler riesen partei
gehen also wenn wir die umfragen glauben
sind sind die beim 25 26
für beide volksparteien historisch sehr
sehr schwach also es gibt in der in
einer möglichen dreier konstellation
nicht mehr diese eine partei die viel
viel stärker ist als ein anderer partner
sondern da sind die kleinen parteien auf
augenhöhe das ist eine chance für aber
ihr und für die option ihn sehr gut sind
wenn sie im bundestag sein wird das ist
doch ein ganz spannender moment haben
wir auch schon mal kurz angeschnitten
aber jetzt sind sie als experte beim
nächsten mal christian lindner ist
ausgestiegen weil die grünen alles
kriegten die hatten aber weitaus weniger
stimmen zumindest in den als in den
umfragen jetzt jetzt kommt eine
geschrumpfte möglicherweise mittel
regierung cdu oder spd da rein sagen wo
ich meine cdu und es kommen die grünen
die massiv angewachsen sind und
erheblich mehr einfluss haben als noch
beim letzten mal wie wollen sie dann als
liberale die grünen bändigen ich würde
erstmal abwarten ob die grünen wirklich
ein gutes wahlergebnis haben die sind ja
jetzt in einigen umfragen schon auf 15
prozent runter geschrumpft waren man
noch produktionen so viel dran und die
wohnen bei den letzten wahlen jedesmal
überbewertet in den umfragen also in
einer umfrage jedoch überbrachte könnte
aber sein dass dies stärker werden als
die liberal und das sind aber auch ganz
andere personen am tisch ja also wir
hatten mit angela merkel besprochen dann
wäre in der konstellation jamal k armin
laschet am tisch der in nrw sehr
vertrauensvoll zusammen regiert und da
auch der fdp mehr raum gibt und das
glaubt mich müssen alle lernen jeder
partei ihre profile auch wenn wir gern
mal die habe ich jetzt mal mengenlehre
mache dann mache das nichts und spd ist
hier und da gibt's überlappung mit den
grünen nicht
so einfach mal mengenlehre kann sie dann
doch ziemlich einfach hat man in mathe
lauren erster bereitet mir ginge hier
die schnittmenge genau und wir stellen
fest so viele schnittmengen ich habe es
einfach jetzt mal ein bisschen
auseinander gesetzt so viele
schnittmengen gibt es zwischen grünen
und fdp und cdu und spd zumindest in
dieser zeit noch nicht mag sein dass es
ein patt gibt gibt es auch in der tat
mussten aber wie es läge wir sehen die
fdp es hier unten das ist jetzt ja aber
hier zuerst das ist finden wir uns auf
jeden fall hätten ihn darin lehrer und
am ende ist immer die frage wenn ich für
eine partei beispielsweise wie die fdp
stimme oder die spd oder die cdu dann
erwarte ich ja etwas wenn ich für die
cdu stimmen beispielsweise markus söder
hat gesagt kein tempolimit obwohl es
ganz viel tempo über in bayern gibt egal
kein tempolimit dann muss sitzt die
union vielleicht in eine koalition mit
den grünen gehen die setzen ein
tempolimit durch weil sie dafür dann auf
steuererhöhungen verzichten
dann sind natürlich unionswähler
möglicherweise auch fdp wähler
frustriert und je größer die koalition
mit also je mehr partner zusammen gehen
die auch gar nicht richtig
zusammenpassen um so größer ist doch der
frust bei denen die diese parteien
gewählt haben fdp bestes beispiel
zwischen 2009 2013 eigentlich eine
liebesheirat wie es immer hieß guido
westerwelle und angela merkel und
trotzdem sind die liberalen vier jahre
später aus dem parlament geflogen auch
im bundesrat richtig weil sie aber ein
zentrales versprechen nicht durchsetzen
konnten das thema steuersenkung also gab
noch ein paar andere probleme aber man
sieht bei der wählerschaft kommt so
etwas nicht gut an ich glaube das ist
die große gefahr
dieser war habe ich auch in die fdp
gegangen weil jugend westerwelle damals
ich bin 2009
miterlebt wie es bergauf gegangen ist
und wir haben auch diesmal wieder klare
rote linien definiert also natürlich
wollen wir inhalte umsetzen
beispielsweise schließen die
steuererhöhungen habe das ist eine rote
linie auch in einer ampel koalition
selbstverständlich wollen wir unsere
inhalte des corsa oder und das werden
wir sehen das entscheiden die
bürgerinnen und bürger sie werden einen
tag vorher keiner oder zwei tage vorher
keine koalitionsaussagen vor aus mir
herauskitzeln können aber das
funktioniert aber wenn man mal 50 50
ampel jamaika oder 30 70 gucken wir mal
vielleicht eine funktion die noch nicht
erwähnt wurde in dieser unglaublich
sachkundigen hier noch
sehr gut an
meine grundschullehrerin machen sich
freuen wenn es gibt noch eine ganz
wichtige funktion für die fdp in welcher
konstellation auch immer ich habe für
eure partei mit das wahnsinnig wichtig
wie in deutschland die dummheiten
gewisse anderen parteien zu verhindern
und dafür zu achten dass wenn gewisse
parteien am ruder sind das noch so ein
restbestand zu spurenelemente von
wirklichkeit bezug von marktwirtschaft
irgendwo in der regierung präsent sind
falls je nach konstellation sich so
ergeben so dass die fdp hat hier auch
eine ganz wichtige rolle sage ich jetzt
mal nicht einfach ihr eigenes programm
über das land zu stellen sondern das
land über dieser über das über die
eigene partei zu stellen das heißt auch
in einer konstellation realpolitisch
einzuwirken dass man zum beispiel die
grünen einfangen kann oder dass man die
spd einfangen kann also ihr dürft nicht
quasi ein programm wie eine bibel wie
ein evangelium sozusagen an die an die
beatles bei und die brillante und die
kirchentür nahrung und sagen bis hierhin
und nicht weiter ihr müsst ihr habt eine
wichtige verantwortung weil in
deutschland
[Musik]